Portability and interoperability and  being able to move between services to  increase innovation and competition and  and enable research so through working  through these issues you know we made a  lot of progress on each of them we've  built up our systems internally in in  elections we made a lot of progress on  each of them we've built up our systems  internally in in elections which I'm  sure we'll get into in a bit there been  many elections around the world over the  last couple of years the results have  been a lot cleaner online due to a lot  of the work that that that we and others  have done in partnership but one of the  things that I've kind of come to after a  few years of really spending most of my  time working on these issues is that in  order to solve these issues you get down  to some fundamental trade-offs and  values